let's start with a survey who here is
using pandas anyway anyone been a by any
chance not using it that's okay
second question list hands up probably
who knows which was their first pandas
version what was it what no but you know
currently were X dot twenty-three dot
for anyone anxious is interested I
started with about dot sixteen the first
reason I'm gonna talk about it is that
the motivation for this talk is that at
work we're using two environments one of
them is old one of them is new for some
reasons and in one we use dot seventeen
and then one we use dot twenty-three
which is the newest one and what I've
learned is that it changed a lot and
that there are many new things in new
pandas that you can do instead of
writing things on your own the first if
I give you a task I'm sure any you're
smart people I'm sure any of you will
get this test done the question is how
many lines of code is going to take you
and how complex mentally it's going to
be and that's the main motivation here
in this slide is that the computer will
understand anything but there are people
that need to maintain this code probably
you in two weeks from now and Daniel
hate the moment that you've written this
bad code if we write a better code
that's better for you I'll have to start
with this slide about my company where
bluevine we're on online lender we give
money to businesses in the United States
who accept this money back and what the
data science is doing is trying to
assess the risk of actually getting the
money back we're hiring specifically if
you're the kind of people that are very
experienced developers but you're here
because you feel like you're a junior in
science we look for these kind of people
to come talk to me if you're by any
chance something like that if you're not
like that we're still hiring so also
come talk to me I think that's enough
about the introduction so let's start
with some imports and we'll start with
the first hat so first we need some data
right we're going to take some data and
we're going to move it into this
pipeline and eventually you're going to
have actually a pipeline whilst that we
have some sections and explain those
stages in the pipeline so first of all
we need to load the data we have some
CSV data of timestamps that's
specifically the data we read it and
then we need to do some housekeeping
work of sorting the values by the date
and then set index on the date and then
there's another column here that I don't
need it's well updated so just drop it
the first heck is this this looks ugly
right it's hard to read then it gets
through the line that you can't see so
the first thing is work with lines right
this is better you actually see what you
can do the thing is you see those
slashes I don't like those for a good
reason first of all you can write
comments inside write something trying
to explain what you're going to do you
can't do this you can just do a
documentation line it just wouldn't work
we expected this error also sometimes it
could be very frustrating when you get
this kind of error anyone understands
why this happens well because of this
space I know it's gonna work but that's
a bad thing
so the point drop first when I realized
well you can be users and we can do this
right this works but also because we we
started with a parenthesis sorry we can
do this etc this also gonna work right
so the first thing thing the first hack
this is not like any smart hack but
like if you don't need to take one thing
from this stock take this start with the
parentheses and then you can write a
pipeline and then just this pipeline it
looks beautiful you can write comments
in it you can do anything you want and
this is going to work second hat that we
need we have this you can see here that
we have event types you have one five
and seven let's say we want to change
those for some reason so first of all we
know we have the math function I guess
you've no debt one the nice thing is
that a dictionary is a callable so a map
X X the color books that's a function
and then it gives you new values that
runs this function on the values the a
dictionary is a callable like like the
first classes in a math in the
university you can they tell you you can
define a function by if you're less than
this and if you're larger than this and
that's okay that's okay so that's kind
of the same thing if you're equal to one
then that's a if you're equal to five
that's B and this will work so this
changing things a lot faster than
writing like many ifs and now we're
starting the actual talk you can see the
entire name and but that works with time
series data no one okay who hates it
speckle a lot more people but okay cool
so resample who knows every sample cool
that's a lot of more people then I
thought the thing is that many of you
will know many things here but probably
none of you will know everything I
didn't know before I wrap this talk and
if anyone gets at least one thing I'm
good with that so let's say I wanna
group by and see how many time stamps or
how many events happened each hour how
are we gonna do that
so the first girl thing would be let's
group by the hour right but that's
that's hard because first I need from
the timestamp understanding what's the
hour so we need to do the index the the
time is the index so let's take the
next from this extract the our extract
today and then group by and first of all
there's this is many lines of code
eventually you get basically you kind of
get what you want but not exactly
there's no lines of codes we have
unneeded columns now the index is not a
time anymore it's like a date and an
integer and the worst thing is that we
have missing rows 7 o'clock like between
7 & 8 nothing happened so group I just
doesn't use that if you do a simple you
can be simple you can tell pandas I want
H H is by the hour and then just count
and this happens a lot faster who
learned something new awesome
it's even better when you used like I
said ok boy one hour it's is I could
have done this by group by the question
becomes what happens when for 1 10
minutes well that would be a mess
writing with a like the old way
extracting the minutes then cutting some
intervals well that's a mess you can
tell pandas resample by 10 T T's for
minute I'm not sure why because M is for
month I guess and you can do this and
just give you a like 500 5 10 5 20 you
can even do if you for some reason want
to you can do like prime numbers pandas
will be okay with that you have a list
of pandas abbreviation and the beautiful
thing about time index is now you can
slice by those indexes in this indices
you can ask pandas give me everything
that happened
I want to see the data frame at around 9
o'clock so you just give it well the
date and the hour so it's a 21 and
pandas gives you 21 let's move back to
the 10 minutes does that's how I'm used
to this top right so everything that
happens at the hour of nine o'clock you
can tell it the same way index by
integers you can just give it some
string of date and you say I want
everything that happens after
6:31 pandas is not doing that sorry
before 631 and here you can see it
finishes at 6:30 cool so now time series
becomes a lot nicer to me because I
hated time series because of mostly the
group I so awesome that's that this is
out of the way but the thing is with the
timing that's it now you can do more
amazing thing you wanna rolling window
we used to write that like take I know
the last six rows maybe loop by some
things you don't have to do this anymore
you have rolling to mean so you just do
a rolling rolling gives you some kind of
object it's like a group by and then you
tell it the function that you want the
mean exactly like and group by and it
does that for you
we have a chart for that but basically
it's a long large font you can do
expanding mean ewm the exponential
weighted moving you tell you tell you
how many periods back I said six and you
just does that for you learn something
new awesome
you can use it with apply for
specifically I want to do a geometric
mean well I didn't find a function for
that so it just wrote one so I take the
product of each group and then I do the
route by the same degree so I'm writing
that side doing apply I'm doing the
rolling that I'm doing apply and it
works and the most beautiful thing which
blew my mind first is that you can
combine group by and the resample so I
had three types of events so I want to
have a column for each type of event and
then we sample for each column so that's
not problem in natural probably in
modern fantasy do a group by then you do
resample then you say which kind of
apply one one account I'm doing some
renaming for some and it happens it
gives you the group by the
if then type and the date and you just
get this you get really well yeah it was
funny when you can see the entire thing
awesome sorting who hates sorting yeah
so the thing would pandas that used to
be is that you have indexes but we're
talking about object indexes indexes not
indices and I think and then you have
you can sort by the values but then you
have indexes so you can maybe sort by
the index so let's start by sorting by
the values everybody knows that you can
just say sort values and by the amount
the amount is the values columns and
that's not a problem the nice thing is
when you are served by index you just
still pandas sorry index well makes
sense the thing is it's sorted by the
event type and only then by date so why
are we doing if you want to do it the
other way around we tell it do it by the
level one right level 0 level one or
some that works the thing is and that's
that's really new and like the last
pandas is that now the in indexes are
accepted
in the sort values and if I want to do a
sort by the amount and then the event
type you just tell it sort values if the
index has a name you just tell it do it
by the amount and the event type and
pandas morning pandas gives that to you
for free second and stack whoa anybody
knows what on step is doing it's kind of
like a pivot table that you used to in
Excel although pandas as a pivot table
we had a double index or multi index and
you can you want to see take one of them
and put it as the columns and then write
the values and inside this two dimension
table so you can do it by pivot table
when I wrote this top I thought this is
gonna be longer but actually they made
pivot table better in self so that's
also another nice
you can do it like this but still you
have to remember watch which values I
want which columns which indexes well
that's a lot of things to think about oh
you can just do one stick by what by the
event type so I wanted the event type I
want to make in two columns they want to
relieve out the other index I can
remember which one
that's not important because pandas
knows that for me and this is also works
now you want to do stack what stack it's
the other way around from unstick so if
I'm I've taken this on stack table I'm
doing the text and a stack and I get the
same thing that but it's not exactly the
same thing right because first of all
you can see pandas is not doing this
pretty that's because it's a series it
not a panda's data frame second of all
the levels are reversed we used to have
the event type on the left and the live
well anyway here's a few tips on how to
get rid of this so we're doing this deck
then instead of saying up like a
constructor do a data frame with the
series pandas there's a nice matter
that's called to frame and you tell it
like the name of the column that's off
the series then you can do swap levels
so we had a multi index like this now
it's like this that's it instead of
starting to maybe reset the index then
set it again by the way you want it swap
level in it's doing this for you then
you sort by index and pandas is doing
all this for free and then if anybody
doesn't know if you want to compare two
data friends if they're equal pandas has
a method for that I used to do like is
this equal to this and if everything is
true than this then it's true but then
if you have nuns the nun is not equal to
nan for some reason so it's false
they're try to meddle anyway pandas is
doing this for you clip is a nice
function that's fairly easy to remember
so a very common test is that some years
sometimes you have values that are not
on the interval that you think they
should be any kind of
to fix the data in our case let's say
that if I have more than less than five
readings or more than twelve I know it's
wrong so I'll just do them those is the
min and the max in the old way I've
started to iterate over the columns then
I'm saying if it's the clipped version
of this is that if it's lower than the
lower bound give it the lower bound if
it's larger than the upper bound give it
the upper bound works but not very
nicely the better way is just tell
pandas do a clip for me here's the lower
bound here's the upper bound we've
switched I know five lines into one
anybody thinks this is cool awesome
reindex so I have this problem I know
the data actually is not from five to
eleven it's from four to twelve and
another thing I know there are more
event types maybe just didn't happen
today they are called Y and C so what
are we supposed to doing the whole old
way I would say okay we have a new
column that's why and it's zero and then
it's dead with a zero the index
well that's many lines of code I didn't
even think about in the new pandas you
can just tell it re-index so first of
all we start with let's create a date
range range is an index so you say start
at for finish at a bit before midnight
and then you give it the frequency the
frequency is the same as you remember
the age the 15 T at this specific case I
want to just take the frequency of the
original data frame say PT that's the
return data frame index and what's the
fret and it gives you the the index now
it's an object's called index it's not
very interesting it's interesting is
when you add it to the data frame and
you tell the data frame re-index with
which index this index on what columns
the e types those are those with the y&z
added and also if anything is missing
give it a fill value of zero
so now you get in one line of code or
maybe two with the date range you get
the same exactly the exact data frame
that you wanted we put this in a
function later will understand why
method chaining what I love about pandas
is you can in like a one line of code
like logically for the computer it's one
line of code we know that you can see we
can write it as many lines but in one
line of code you can do actually the
entire pipeline not like break it and
then say data frame this column equals
this it's something we used to do we can
do this and also the chaining of the
method of the pipeline and that's called
a sign so let's let's say I want to take
the mean of all the events like it
doesn't matter how many events happen
just I wanted the mean of all the some
columns I can tell it a sign mean all
equals and what's the function what what
I want there that's the function on the
data frame and it just gives it to you
in the same one-liner method chaining
but what happens if I want to take
something longer I want to do some
really complex function on the data
frame that I can't actually write in one
code well I can write a function that
would be a bit uglier but I take it
outside to my package I've written like
an helper pack a helper package but I
want to I want to take this function
this function accepts a data frame and
returns a data frame so if I have that I
can put it inside the pipeline how am I
doing this with the method called pipe
so I'm telling it let's write this
helper function it takes it adds some
number to the column so first method
would be to actually write these nesting
nested functions though it happened in
Reverse like SQL I don't like that you
can make it easier with three lines of
data frame equals function on data frame
data frame equals function data frame
etc the more beautiful way would be to
just tell you
pipe pipe Edie to call now I donate
because I want to do two hundred to a
those are the default parameters so I
just don't need to write anything if I
want to change those I just give it give
the pipe the new parameters so add a
hundred to being 500 to see and you get
this so I'm moving I'm starting with the
end of the talk
why am I telling you all of this
beautiful code tells a story the way
people understand is by is with with
stories with actual will actual English
that tells them what's happening so if
we're writing beautiful code the
maintainer is later again probably you
in a month you want to see what's
happening as fast as you can and not
start fighting with the code to see what
actually happens and now we're going to
do this entire talk in one cell and
that's it there's our many lines of code
but they actually speak pretty good
English you take a CSV you read a CSV
then you sign it some function which
turns ones into a thousand to be etc I
serve the value as I said them as an
index I dropped something that I don't
need a group by every sample I apply
it's everything is English writers are
like English words that you understand
I've put the remove multi index as a
function I can edit as a pipe but it
still remains a story eventually I take
a slice of it just the main event and I
want to do some maybe time series
analysis for Jess I need sliding windows
so I've written a pretty ugly functions
it's called make sliding windows it's
pretty ugly but the thing is that unless
I maintain this specific function I
don't need to go back to it I just tell
it pipe make sliding windows and that's
all I need to know and then you can see
this happens you get timestamps you get
like mean event mean event - 1 - 2 etc
this used to be the end of the talk I
have some bonus material if you want it
if not what ok so a few more function
methods that I like about pandas those
are not in the same pipeline as before
but who needed like did you have a use
case when you needed to see how a column
changes like my percentage like this
values is 2 times larger than your
values before that used to write it by
making some like shifting it by 1 then
see how much is this well you don't need
to because pandas as a function for
judge
it's called percent change and pandas is
doing it for you for free
interval index that's something fairly
new that I've learned about recently
the thing with time series is when I say
on three o'clock we had 7 events is that
3 - 4 or 2 - 3 both answers are okay as
long as it's consistent and the problem
becomes consistency between developers
between other scientists and between you
and yourself and because sometimes you
want to group by and then you started
thinking about it and it's not easy
so penny says an interval index so you
remember a day time range that we've
done before now you have internal
interval range you say when you want it
to start when you want it to end so it
started by the same data frame that we
had before we start at the mean time we
end with the max time and a bit more and
at what frequency and pandas gives that
to you you can see that it's new objects
called interval index I didn't show you
how it looks
looks ugly why is that not working we
know well that's nicer so you can see
everything between 5:30 and 5:45 etc why
is that nice because then I can ask
pandas what happens on 6:30 7:00 we'll
start with the later so if you had the
time index nothing happens in 637
panda's knows about 6:30 and 6:45 if you
give it an endured in to arrange well
this is the one I just gave it an
integer range and then it knows well the
name is 6:30 to 6:45 and those are the
values anybody knew about this before us
split strings did you add did you have a
case when you need to split the strings
with Steve one of them inside the data
frame but then you only wanted the first
word and then you've done this but then
it gives you a column with the list then
how do you extract a list well you have
a nice keyword argument it's called
expand equals true and it just gives you
the debt and then you can just it will
give me the first call toy examples with
pandas testing that's one things I want
one thing I want you to learn but then
we will use it in a second for some
things so if you just want to test some
stuff and you want to get a data frame
fast you have inside pandas util testing
you have a make time data frame and then
I've told it I want it 15 by 10 and it
just gives me a 15 by 10 data frame now
we can play with it so the last thing
the last thing I want to talk about is
research with style this will probably
not go into production
but sometimes you want to take a data
frame then you want to see it with some
colors so what I used to do is exporting
it as an excel file then do some
conditional formatting then I started
using Mac and I didn't have Excel and
the numbers app it's not very good plan
this do everything for you so let's put
some nuns in day just to see that yep so
you get an excess so you do you take the
data framing first of all you tell it
dot style and then you get a style or
object that you can you have many
methods on the first method is highlight
now so you're going you're going to see
in a second that the higher the nulls
are gonna be read but then you can also
tell it highlight Max and I like I
really mean with still blue and gold
what you can see is that I've totally
give the max on the axis one and the
mean on X is zero so if we're looking
for that pandas will start coloring
everything the nuns are red the max on
columns or you have one blue in each
column and one yellow in each row you
can see sometimes you want to say in
Excel you have like give me a value
range pandas has that it's just called
background gradient you can see that the
lower values are pretty white the larger
values are really dark blue you can give
it a custom function so in my case I'm
saying I'm telling like if you need to
know a bit of CSS code but like the
simplest of the CSS code you tell it if
the value is less than minus 100 the
break on color is red and if its larger
than green if the absolute value is
something than yellow you can just tell
the styling object apply map for the
function and you get everything that's
nice if you have like many columns and
you want to see some irregular data or
stuff like that that's pretty nice to
research with it the last thing is the
bars it just give you the data like this
even has like two-sided bars oh it's not
as I put it in the end I see if you like
awesome so to summary this is we need to
make this a bit smaller
this is Greg Rader he's a guy who wrote
like a very known tutorial on pandas
it's been seen like hundreds of stuff in
his time and it is saying that he's
doing it for six years and he's reading
the tutorial and still it doesn't know
what's more smoothly index and that's
okay if you don't remember anything from
my talk that's okay you don't have to go
home and like write in the notebook
resample the style stick instead it's
not important the thing is that you
realize that if you have some objective
that you want to do and you can realize
that maybe I'm not the first one that's
doing it in the world then probably
modern pandas have the thing for you
the best thing thing I've learned about
in the last year like now it's a few
months but there is simple thing it's
like it's amazing it's changed my life
those are some resources that I've used
and that's it questions everybody's a
pandas expert